you know dan i think there's a big
difference between pollution
and climate change and we've seen
bureaucrats like john kerry at the epa
similar kinds of people sue ranchers and
farmers
out of their livelihoods out of their
homes because they have some kind of
wetland on their property or something
else i mean
it is like a class issue when it comes
to the issue of the environment it seems
more and more you know as a party elder
which i would say john kerry is
he is not the right spokesperson for
this issue
when if if you are going to start your
uh administration off by talking about
killing these jobs
and not having a plan for them and just
saying well they can just get another
job like they can just make a solar
panel like
obviously it's so easy like because we
have just gone through four years
i'm sorry eight years of the obama
administration we proved in the last
segment
that those jobs didn't come to fruition
why not take just
half a minute like maybe half a year to
say hey guys look
here's all these jobs that have been
created like we've created all these
jobs so
you now it's safe for you it's okay for
you to come now
and and have these other jobs and we're
going to train you're going to do that
but instead they're just like
yeah you'll get a new job but they're
not proving that that can actually work
i
think it's a very strange way to try to
win back working class
voters yeah and the jobs aren't
in existence yet jessie it's like quit
your job we're eliminating your job but
the industry's not ready yet for you
they already tried it
obama spent billions to train west
virginia miners
how to become drone operators nurses
and computer programmers the program was
a bust
katie they tried to train colorado
miners
to become solar panel builders and they
were making
75k mining and then they made
40 000 building panels so they got them
fired
and then they cut their salary in half
you think that's a good policy
no i mean i mean these people are idiots
why is john kerry the czar of anything
that's also terrible all right